-As Republicans salivate over
the discovery of a small number
of classified documents
in Joe Biden's home
and private office,
Donald Trump's
many criminal probes
are intensifying,
and Trump is freaking out.
In response, he called in
to a right-wing radio show
and called the special counsel
investigating him
a terrorist.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Going into last year's midterms,
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
and his fellow Republicans were
expecting a landslide victory
that would give them a large
majority in the House
and a mandate to go on offense
against Joe Biden
and the Democrats.
In fact, for at least a year
leading up to the midterms,
McCarthy was incredibly cocky
about it, even giving out
specific numbers
for how many seats Republican
could win.
-It could be one of the biggest
election losses for Democrats.
I think anywhere over 20
is a red wave.
We want to earn enough that
we have a governing majority.
That means getting in the realm
of 20 and higher.
If we were fortunate enough
to win 35 Republican seats,
that would be the largest
Republican majority
in more than 100 years.
There's about 55 to 70 seats
that we can play in
and make them competitive.
-Is there any chance Republicans
are a little overconfident
this year?
-No, we're not overconfident.
-"There's gonna be historic
red wave or my name's not
Klevin McCorthy.
[Bleep] Hold on!"
[ Laughter ]
It's never a good sign
when someone says
they're not being
overconfident.
If a character says that in
a movie, he's about 10 minutes
away from getting eaten
by a T-Rex.
"I'm not overconfident!
I'm your only way
out of this park!
[ Screams ]"
[ Laughter ]
McCarthy was so overconfident,
he was even predicting
the safe blue seats where Biden
beat Trump by double digits
would be vulnerable to
Republicans, and he warned
the members of Congress
in those seats
that they could soon be
out of jobs.
-If you're a Democrat,
and President Biden
won your seat by 16 points,
you're in a competitive race
next year.
You are no longer safe.
-"You are no longer safe"?
Are you a member of Congress
or a stalker ex-husband
from a Lifetime movie
called "Taking back the House?"
[ Laughter ]
"Kevin!
What are you doing here?!
You don't live here anymore!"
"I helped pay for this house,
Carol, and if you think
I'm gonna stand by while you
turn into the town harlot,
you are sadly mistaken!
You are no longer safe!"
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the point is, McCarthy
was confidently predicting
enough seats for what he called
a governing majority,
meaning majority big enough
that he could get stuff done
without having to beg and plead
with every individual member
of his caucus.
As we all know now,
that did not happen,
and McCarthy had to concede
to virtually anything
anyone wanted from him
to get their vote.
For example,
allowing just one Republican
to call for a vote
to remove him as Speaker
at any time -- one member.
That means any time
Lauren Boebert has a bad day,
she can take it out on
Kevin McCarthy,
which is a problem because
she only has bad days.
Don't get me wrong --
she loves bad days.
She's built for bad days.
She's the only person
who wears a T-shirt that says,
"Thank God it's Monday."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the point is,
McCarthy had to beg and plead
to get his job,
and for help with that,
he turned to Donald Trump.
Now, as we've explained before,
Trump is actually a big reason
McCarthy has
such a small majority
in the first place.
Instead of staying out
of the primary process,
and letting more conventional
GOP candidates
win their races,
Trump kept endorsing
his collection of MAGA goons.
McCarthy would say,
"Here's a good choice.
He's pro-military
and anti-taxes."
And then Trump would say,
"I also have a guy.
He's for sure a pyromaniac..."
[ Laughter ]
"...and he once punched a horse
at a county fair,
but he also has my name tattooed
on his forehead,
so he's a sharp guy."
[ Laughter ]
If it wasn't for Trump-endorsed
candidates failing
in the general election,
Republicans probably would have
won a lot more seats,
and McCarthy would have breezed
through the Speaker vote.
Instead, Trump tanked the party,
and McCarthy's razor-thin margin
relies on Trump fanatics.
So to get them on board,
McCarthy had to rely on
Trump's help,
which he openly admitted.
-I do want to especially thank
President Trump.
I don't think he should --
anybody should doubt
his influence.
He was with me
from the beginning.
Somebody wrote the doubt
is why he was there,
and he was all in.
And he was a great influence
to make that all happen,
so thank you, President Trump.
-As a general rule, it's weird
to publicly thank someone
who is under multiple
criminal investigations.
During her Golden Globes speech,
Jennifer Coolidge
didn't thank the actual Italian
Mafia, although in her case,
I don't think she should
thank anyone.
She's Jennifer Coolidge.
She should give
a "you're welcome" speech.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
She should just get up there,
take her award,
say, "Wow!"
And then just walk off.
[ Laughter ]
But the last person you should
be thanking is Trump.
That's the point at which
McCarthy
should have been played off.
-I do want to especially
thank, uh, President Trump.
[ Fanfare plays loudly ]
I don't think...
-Of course,
this year's Golden Globe
had that haunting piano --
the same haunting piano
that plays in
"Taking Back the House"
when Kevin emerges
from behind the curtain.
[ Haunting piano music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
The point is,
the Speaker of the House
is now publicly indebted
to a guy who openly plotted
a coup against
the United States government.
In fact, the multiple
criminal investigations
into Trump are now intensifying.
On Friday, for example,
Trump's family company
was hit with the maximum fine
allowed under New York State law
for running a years-long
tax fraud scheme.
-Tonight the Trump Organization
has been hit
with the maximum penalty --
$1.6 million --
after being found guilty
of a years-long scheme
to pay top executives
with cars, apartments,
and school tuition,
all to avoid paying tax.
-No, I think it's great
that Trump's company
was held criminally accountable.
But only $1.6 million?
Trump probably
keeps that much change
in his big-ass coat.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look.
He looks like he should be
standing in line
at a Coinstar machine.
Trump's company got
the maximum fine
from a criminal tax-fraud
conviction.
Then, we found out last week
that the Justice Department
has issued yet another
flurry of subpoenas
to Trump officials
as part of their investigation
into the coup attempt
on January 6th.
-We are keeping a new eye
on some new moves
in that DOJ
criminal investigation
into January 6th,
with the Washington Post
now reporting on its new
and wide-ranging subpoena
that the Justice Department sent
to Trump campaign officials.
It asks some new questions
related to the 6th,
according to The Post,
for information
about stuff like
what these people said
about voting machines
after 2020;
for documents about
the fundraising and planning
that went into
then-President Trump's
rally on the 6th.
-Now, this is big,
because you know
what the punishment is
for instigating a coup.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
-One million dollars.
[ Laughter ]
-Big-time stuff.
But more subpoenas
are going out.
For example, prosecutors
have subpoenaed Mike Pence
to find out what the [Bleep]
is going on with this run.
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department needs to
get to the bottom of that.
The only time it makes sense
to run and clap at the same time
is if your dog is humping
a stranger's leg in the park.
"Atlas, no! No!
Atlas, no humping!
We discussed this!"
[ Laughter ]
And we played this clip
last week,
and somehow
it was the first time
I and a lot of our viewers
had seen it.
And it only
raised more questions.
I mean, look at
the rhythm of his clapping.
He's...
[ Laughter ]
...like the weirdest metronome
I've ever seen.
He's like a -- like a T-1000
that got reprogrammed.
[ Laughter ]
And there may be new areas
of investigative interest,
but it's a lot of the old names.
For example, prosecutors
are focused yet again
on a close Trump ally
who has been in and out
of legal trouble,
basically nonstop,
for several years now.
-Former Trump attorney
Rudy Giuliani
has been subpoenaed
for documents
related to payments he received
around the 2020 election.
A source tells CNN
the subpoena is
part of Special Counsel
Jack Smith's
sweeping criminal probe into
Trump's fundraising and spending
as he tried to overturn
the 2020 election.
That's right,
Rudy was subpoenaed.
I bet I know what face he made
when he found out.
Ooh. I tricked you.
You guys thought
I was gonna show
the one where his eyes
are bugging out of his head.
[ Laughter ]
No, that's not how Rudy
would react to a subpoena.
That's how he'd react
to seeing Mike Pence run.
[ Laughter ]
Mike Pence runs like
one of those ball thingies
bosses have in movies
on their desk.
[ Laughter ]
It won't surprise you to learn
that all this has made Trump
very unhappy.
Last week, he called in
to a right-wing radio show
and threw a hissy fit
about the special counsel
who's investigating him --
a guy named Jack Smith.
-Hey! First of all,
no one should be
held responsible
for what
their wife's sister does,
my man!
[ Laughter ]
That's not cool!
Bad enough you got to
spend all day worrying
what your wife's doing
behind your back.
But her sister?
[Bleep] you, dude.
[ Laughter ]
Also, how does Trump even have
all of this information
about a guy's extended family?
Is he just sitting down
with ancestry.com every night,
looking for new enemies?
"I just got a hint leaf,
and it says that his wife
has a sister
who does not like
Trump or cilantro."
[ Laughter ]
This is, yet again,
one of the many differences
between the situations Trump and
Biden find themselves in.
Trump is under multiple separate
criminal investigations.
He's lied about them
at every turn,
refused to cooperate,
obstructed the investigations,
and is now calling the
prosecutor investigating him
a terrorist.
Biden is at least cooperating.
The worst thing you could say
about Biden is,
there was no reason for him
to keep classified documents
in the garage where
he also parks his Corvette.
-According to
President Joe Biden,
these classified documents were
found in his personal library
and in the garage of his home
in Wilmington, Delaware.
Just moments ago,
Biden addressed the matter
very briefly, saying
it was a locked garage where
he also keeps his Corvette.
-Let me -- I'm gonna get
a chance to speak
on all of this, God willing,
soon.
But as I said earlier this week,
people --
And by the way, my Corvette
is in a locked garage.
Okay? So it's not like you're
sitting out in the street.
But as I said earlier this week,
people know
I take classified documents and
classified material seriously.
I also said
we're cooperating fully
and completely with the
Justice Department's review.
-But why were the documents
specifically
next to the Corvette?
Does he think reading documents
make you look like a nerd,
so he wanted something kick-ass
next to them?
"Mr. President, we have
intelligence on North Korea
you need to read ASAP."
"Aw, my Corvette's too far away.
Get me my Ray-Bans
and my Harley jacket."
[ Laughter ]
House Republicans are trying
to go after Biden
and protect Trump,
but the two situations
are in no way comparable.
Trump is under multiple
criminal investigations
for many things,
from his family business
to his coup attempt
to his refusal to hand over
classified documents.
Biden is at least cooperating.
When the Feds
showed up at Mar-a-Lago,
Trump didn't exactly run to the
door like this.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]